hey everyone i'm abby sharp welcome to
abby's kitchen
today's video is sponsored by magic
spoon and i'm going to take you on a
little vlog adventure of
all the takeout and delivery food i ate
in a month
as well as some really easy tips for
ordering it now before we get talking
about ordering dinner
let's chat about my favorite meal of the
day breakfast
so raise your hands if you remember the
good old days
when breakfast was just a simple bowl of
cereal
rather than some elaborate kale smoothie
bowl or avocado toast
i mean i love those breakfasts too but
sometimes i just want to keep it super
simple
and cereal never disappoints i
am admittedly obsessed with cereal and i
keep a wide range of cereals in my
pantry
at all times so i've got baby friendly
cereals i've got old lady brand cereal
and i've got a few fun nostalgic cereals
as well
so yeah i don't discriminate but i also
don't
usually expect to be getting my morning
protein fix
from a bowl of cereal grains so i was
really excited when i got sent this
magic spoon variety pack and i notice it
has an impressive 14 grams of protein
and because it has no added sugar in it
i'll often pair it with some greek
yogurt
and like a mountain of fruit just to
make a more substantial breakfast or
post-workout snack
it's also an insanely delicious middle
of the night breastfeeding snack
or afternoon car snack just eaten by the
handful
right out of the box as is and if you or
your family members have dietary
restrictions
it's naturally free of gluten grains and
soy
so right now there's four flavors cocoa
fruity frosted and the new
limited edition peanut butter and get
all four
in their new variety pack i am currently
obsessed with mixing the peanut butter
and the cocoa flavors together to make a
breakfast that
legit tastes like peanut butter cups so
if you want to get nostalgic and give
this cereal a try
you can go to magicspoon.com abby sharp
and use my promo code abby sharp to get
five dollars off of your order
and if you aren't in love with your
breakfast magic spoon will refund your
money
no questions asked okay before we get
into it a quick disclaimer that this is
not a suggestion on how to eat what to
eat or how
much to eat these are just some random
meals that i ordered in the past month
or so in covid which tells you
nothing about what i ate earlier on in
the day or
week or even how much of these i ate
every body and every palette is
different so
please just use these tips if you find
them helpful but ultimately
let your body be your guide now contrary
to what you might expect from a
dietitian
this is not going to be a typical
healthy
or diet friendly guide to takeout you
can find tons of lists online where
people will tell you to
order your sauce on the side or avoid
anything with the words crispy or
breaded in the description or to split
an appetizer with your friend as
your main this is not that kind of list
instead for those of you who are
struggling with some anxiety or fear
around eating takeout
or restaurant food since you lack that
sense of control with it
i want to hopefully help you loosen the
reins especially in these challenging
coveted times
i don't know about you but i feel like a
lot of my
normal life pleasures are inaccessible
right now to me
and food is one of the only things that
i look forward to each week
outside of spending time with my family
and kids so i'm definitely
trying to exercise some extra compassion
and empathy towards myself right now
and ultimately spend a little bit more
of my monthly budget on ordering in
i'm also friends with a ton of people in
the restaurant industry and
i acknowledge how brutally tough this is
on them right now
so my husband and i agreed that if we
wanted our favorite spots to make it to
the other side when you know we could
maybe sit down at the bar for a drink
with them again
we would have to support them through
this hell so for the ultimate sake of an
industry that i love
for my sanity as a working mom and for
my own pleasure
and fun i probably order in or take out
at least two times per week now i
acknowledge that this is a totally
privileged experience so i'm in no way
suggesting that this is something that
everyone should do
but anyways enjoy this little montage of
the past month or so of my takeaways
while i ramble off some intuitive eating
tips that i have found useful
to hopefully help to temper your
anxieties around ordering
in and help you foster a more relaxed
relationship with restaurant foods
kiddos are down vino is poured
pizza is smelling damn good
number one no more cheat meals first of
all guys
can we just get rid of the term cheat
meal from our vocabulary
thank you very much i know i say it all
the time
but restricting all week only to binge
at your epic cheat meal or cheat day
is not the road to good health when you
have a balanced relationship with food
where you can have ice cream on a
tuesday and salad on a friday
you can order what you feel like in that
moment
and not make it be based on a need to
either only order
super clean salads or over-the-top
heavy fare if i'm having a super busy
week and i end up ordering in
two nights in a row for example usually
by the second night
i often just don't feel like having
another like fried chicken dinner or
pizza
i genuinely just want a soup or salad
and call it a day this isn't about
trying to repent or restrict after
eating
too many fries this is about checking in
with my body to see what it needs and
sometimes it needs fried chicken and
sometimes it needs some veggie soup
my body is really smart number two use
restaurant food to explore
new foods so i like to think about
takeout or delivery
as an opportunity to teach my family
something new about food
this can be for the parents like me who
want to introduce their kids to
new flavors or different cultures but
also
just for yourself as well so a lot of
the recipes on my blog were actually
inspired by meals that i had
in some amazing restaurants and
basically i would just attempt to
recreate them somehow in more everyday
balanced
or cost-effective ways i also often like
to order in things that maybe i wouldn't
normally want to make or be able to
easily make
so that way my kids or my son can be
exposed to new flavors and combinations
so for example i don't personally cook a
lot of meat
in my house anymore so if i really do
want a burger
i usually will order it in i also don't
have the equipment
time or in some cases skill to make
things like
sushi really good thai curry fried
chicken
or beautiful italian pasta sauces that
will take
all day to cook so these are some of the
things that would contribute to my food
ordering decisions
so my tip here is to let your culinary
curiosity
guide your ordering decisions what do
you want your family to try
that you just can't be bothered making
yourself and if you do try something
that you
absolutely love maybe challenge yourself
at a future date
to try to recreate it at home with your
own recipe
number three love your leftovers yes
even the really indulgent stuff actually
especially
the really indulgent stuff in the past i
would plan this like
epic cheat meal where i would allow
myself to eat the pizza that i maybe
would otherwise never allow myself to
eat and then as i'm eating and i'm
starting to feel full
i would convince myself that i would
have to eat the entire
thing in that sitting because tomorrow i
would be back to eating boiled eggs and
green juice we call this the last supper
mentality
the result is that we eat well past our
satiety signals
consuming far more calories than we
actually need
and we don't even enjoy the food like
i love pizza but pizza when i'm stuffed
already from eating a lot of pizza just
never
tastes the same as that first bite when
i actually have an appetite
so here's a little secret despite what
your restriction voice
is telling you you can save that
leftover slice for tomorrow
and consume those same calories when
you're actually
going to enjoy it more the result is
that you'll likely end up eating fewer
calories overall since
that leftover meal would theoretically
take the place of your
clean oatmeal bowl or avocado toast
so my tip here is to challenge yourself
to check in with your body throughout
the meal
and if you're feeling drawn to continue
eating even after you're full
ask yourself why get curious challenge
the false logic
that you need to eat up all of the bad
food in the house during your arbitrary
cheat meal
so that you can start fresh clean eating
tomorrow
maybe even challenge yourself to save
that last slice of pizza
or even a single roll of sushi for the
next day
see how that feels you don't need to
just get rid of it
just because it's there if you're just
not hungry for it
and when you do eat it notice how it
makes you feel
notice if it tastes better when you're
actually hungry
or what thoughts this brings up for you
this will actually take a lot of
practice but it is really freeing
when you can get out of that all or
nothing mentality around when you can
and can't eat something now when i order
in
i often order extra on purpose knowing
that my family and i might want like a
really easy lunch that i don't have to
cook the next day
it's not a cheat day it's just another
day i did not sleep well last night oh
decide to be up
a lot so i'm having leftover mac and
cheese for breakfast
and there's nothing strange about that
yeah it's 6 45
but that is what i'm feeling and i'm
going to give myself
whatever i want today and yes i'm aware
i like mac and cheese with my ketchup
don't judge me i'm just i don't have the
patience to be judged right now
now number four make the dish delicious
for
you so as a foodie i say
ideally we want to trust the chefs to do
their thing
when you can but choose to customize to
meet your needs when you can't
i've worked with a lot of chefs over the
years and if i can say anything about
them it's that they are very proud of
their craft
they've trained so hard to come up with
these innovative flavor combinations
so i do try to trust them to just put
that dish together
how they want it whenever i can but
ultimately
you're the customer and you're the one
paying for the food
so if you don't like mushrooms or you
can't eat dairy
then customization is a beautiful thing
there are so many great places now that
allow you to add
or remove various ingredients based on
your dietary restrictions and
preferences
so whether that might mean choosing your
own pizza or
taco toppings or building a really
nutritious
salad or bowl this is really key if you
have allergies or intolerances
but also it can help you build a more
balanced bowl or meal
so maybe that means adding a protein to
your salad
or some extra veggies to your sandwich
if it makes the experience
more enjoyable and the meal more
satiating
and satisfying to you i think that these
customization options
are really great expensive but still
great
i mean i know that i always end up with
like a 20 salad because
i see this list of 50 cent add-ons and
i'm like
oh i like this and i like this and i
like this and i like this and oh yes yes
double cheese thank you very much
so yeah i guess we gotta balance
budget with our preferences too and
speaking of budget my next tip is to
supplement your take out with
something homemade now if you're looking
to build a more
balanced meal that is also more cost
conscious
one thing that i sometimes do is i'll
make my own salad or side
so for example maybe what i'm feeling
like ordering like
soup for example just isn't likely going
to be enough to really
fill me up for a meal but maybe i don't
want to spend more money
on buying a side or a salad when i know
that i've got the ingredients
in my fridge to throw something together
super fast
so what do i do i have both this can
save me a lot of money since
i often find that salads from some
restaurants that aren't actual salad
restaurants
they're kind of meh and they're also
usually super overpriced
but putting a bowl of like steamed
vegetables or salad
or some rice or bread on the table just
helps make for a more
balanced satisfying meal are you team
rice or team noodle i am definitely a
noodle girl but i love me
some progress
next know that not all your takeaway
meals need to be
perfectly balanced in fact i would say
at least
for me half the time mine are like just
straight up carbs
and i'm okay with that i know that in a
lot of my reviews you see me critique
individual meals but i do that so that
you have
ideas on how to make that particular
meal or meal like that
more satiating and more balanced in the
real world
it wouldn't matter if you had zero
vegetables at dinner other than i guess
like tomato sauce
on pizza or that it's low in protein
because you just wanted
straight up carbs that's how i roll like
all the time
and i have zero shame in that but i also
know
that if i look at the big picture it
will all balance itself out
i know that i probably had some salad
for lunch or
fruit as a snack with some beans or eggs
or fish or chicken in the day there for
protein
and the next day i'm probably gonna
start my day with yogurt and fruit
because
if i'm listening to my body i usually do
wake up after a
salty rich meal craving something
fresh so ultimately trust your body and
don't be so hard on yourself if the
macros are not perfect
at every meal and finally don't freak
out if the meal
doesn't live up to the hype i think when
we limit our consumption of
fun foods to just like a cheat day or a
cheat meal we put an enormous amount of
stock
into everything that we eat we might be
nervous to try something new because
we're worried it won't live up to like
our cheat day standards
or we feel deeply disappointed
when something arrives that maybe is not
what we were expecting
or ordered repeat after me tomorrow
is another delicious day not all meals
are going to be home runs and that goes
for homemade ones too
now i get that there's added
disappointment when you've spent good
money on something so
sometimes i do try to doctor something
up by adding like a sauce or some kind
of seasoning
if i think it's salvageable but
sometimes you just gotta say
hey you know what it filled my belly it
did
its job next time i'll order something
else
and that my friends is how you support
your local restaurant industry when it's
financially feasible to you
and also help make your life easier and
more fun
without unnecessary anxiety around
restaurant food
so a big thank you again to magic spoon
for sponsoring
if you like this video be sure to give
it the thumbs up leave me a comment
below with your
go-to take out food what do you love to
order i want to know if you're in
toronto let me know where i should be
ordering from and
definitely check out the list below in
some of my favorite restaurants
don't forget to subscribe to the channel
and i will see you next time on abby's
kitchen
bye